oh damn this is her moment to become a
three sport world champion Tom sohee the
number two Contender has now reeled off
nine straight wins I'm excited about the
interim Adam wave title is going to be
electrifying
right through the city like British
[Music]
boys
what's up fam welcome Monday morning it
is Monday morning September 25th
yeah man that's it it's Monday morning
that's our show uh how's everybody doing
out there hopefully as you're listening
to this or watching this at work right
now just dropped off the kiddos and
you're preparing for your day appreciate
you guys checking in with your boy here
fresh off the plane from Spokane Spokane
Washington
uh it's Spokane I stayed in a hotel
where Ted Bundy also stayed I learned
that after the fact not July I was
scared uh
uh forget the name the Davenport the
Davenport Hotel in Spokane apparently
it's the most haunted place in Spokane
uh my brother Jay books the hotels
doesn't believe in ghosts and looked
that stuff up and I do so it's a bit of
a problem didn't sleep great didn't
sleep great at all
um so yeah we stayed in a haunted hotel
and Ted Bundy stayed there before so
that's cool
um outside that man uh yesterday rushed
on a freaking basically a red eye to
make my son's baseball game and then uh
my jmb intake arrived three and a half
weeks later that's how it goes when you
ordered performance parts and I was
chomping at the bit to install that bad
boy uh here's the thing about installs
follow the instructions follow the
instructions and use the pieces that
they gave you my thinking was I'm just
gonna use the stock Parts if I can like
the screws and the certain bolts and
stuff because it's there for a reason
and uh no they give it to you for a
reason they they definitely give you the
parts because uh they know what they're
doing so it took me twice as long
because that uh I installed it took it
off because I didn't use their parts
then reinstalled it but you'll learn as
you go you learn as you go that thing is
squealing like a piggy in the hot summer
days right now
um but when you think about it I drive
up to Sacramento on uh later this week I
drive to Sacramento with my brother Jay
to drop it off at Overkill they're just
going to take it all off and then do it
by themselves and so it's kind of it was
a learning experience that's all I
wanted to do man but yeah once it gets
to Overkill we'll see what's up that
thing's gonna be a freaking Savage I
can't wait we'll be documenting all of
it we'll have some cool content for you
guys if your uh Gearheads out there and
you're thick and quick this is the
Journey For You thick and quick that's
the that's the nickname of the the TRX
demon thick and quick it's basically a
yacht on land and you just put all this
power behind it but uh as far as the
fight World goes
you know this is the first week in a
long time we don't have a big UFC event
to look forward to which is all good uh
you got college football popping right
now
um to see Buffs listen if as a Colorado
boy it was a tough weekend if you're a
Colorado fan because the Buffs lost to
Oregon uh which kind of expected you
know people go
you know all what's up cu's not real you
know the all this hype you know the
media hyped it and I told you guys the
start of the season is the expectations
put on cu
are so outrageously insane and I told
the the expectations man that all these
people are put on we won one game last
year we've already won three and beat
TCU who's a top 20 team we're doing just
fine and then when you say no we're good
man it's way better than last year like
oh moving the field goal moving the
field post here I'm like yeah we're way
ahead of schedule for my expectations
where I never thought we were going to
beat Oregon now part of me is like yeah
I bet it goes better than we thought it
didn't we don't have an online d-line
when you play against the big dogs
that's what happens so they'll get there
but everybody's like oh we knew they
were over hype those are those were your
weird expectations of them I I'm
perfectly happy where we are SC I think
they do better but are they gonna be
that seat to be damn tough as these
defense ain't [__] though so we need the
the offense be firing on all cylinders
but those that old lines give me an
issue man all season long all season
long I've been they go to bowl game
which is insane to say look my
expectations are I better get a bowl
game
what bowl game I don't know probably a
pretty good one because they bring
eyeballs down but if for them to win one
game last year and Dion taking a bowl
game is historic they're probably gonna
make some horrible movie about this in
20 years so get your mind right and I
bet it's way better than Rudy Rudy's
offsides
um so you know C got their butts kicked
and then uh the Broncos I wasn't able to
watch it the NFL's hard for me to watch
because Sundays I'm usually with the
kiddos they're Sports so NFL football is
hard to watch I catch the highlights or
I have NFL Red Zone uh sometimes Sunday
Night Football Monday Night Football
every now and then it's kind of hard to
watch
um I saw my Broncos lost 70 to 20. 70
points
seven how somebody not getting fired 70
to 20 I thought it was a joke
my dad text me he's like our Broncos
look awful I'm like oh when is the last
second touchdown he goes no no it's 70
to 20. I'm like is this the in that's on
her in the NFL that's I mean that's
unheard of I don't think anybody's gonna
be this bad since the 60s and they could
have they could have been had the
all-time record most points scored ever
if that coach was you know feeling
froggy he could just kick the field goal
I mean the most points ever scored in
the game how somebody's head's not
rolling Sean Payne's or Russell Wilson I
I don't know somebody should be fired
and that didn't that doesn't happen in
professional sports the tackling was
atrocious it's it's tough right now to
be a Broncos fan but if you're feeling
froggy I think they play the bear soon
which is going to be the worst NFL game
of all time you need the experts to help
help you out and that's why you need
fancy Guru fancy gurus can do expert
picks from UFC NFL MLB the Dodgers are
popping right now Atlanta looks
unstoppable my my Padres are a winning
streak they're five back you know and
there's I think there's six games left
so we'll see what's up we will see
what's up
um but yeah you can partner up with uh
fancy Guru they have all the pop-in
picks from legit experts not me not
Drake not your mom's boyfriend he
doesn't know crap about sports uh we're
talking about legit experts who help you
make the picks when you use DraftKings
and you can earn your shot over a
million dollars in prizes every Sunday
the Monday night are great the Thursday
nights are great and they have UFC all
right so the experts are doing my pick
from now on sick of this just go to
fancyguru.com use promo code shop you
get 20 off the entire site so you can
get expert picks so stop using your
mom's boyfriend as your expert picker
use fancy Guru go to fancy guru.com use
promo code chob
oh this NFL season's crazy
as well right after all right okay all
right I don't want to do that all right
uh also any show that you see your boy
on I'm using happy hippo happy hippo it
will get your brain fired up it's like
that giant intake that looks like a huge
red penis that I put on my truck but for
your brain we're talking about happy
hippo grab them that's right have you
want your Kratom the only trick uh
company that I trust is happy hippo it's
a wild west out there with CBD and the
and kratom's no different and you gotta
trust your Kratom company that's why I
partnered with Happy Hippos
happyhippo.com promo code is thick23 you
get 20 off for Life the highly
concentrated shots the energy shots
which I use about way too much three
times a day they also have the Kratom
pouches the first ever to Market K dips
wintergreens my go-to here
um they're doing it right man so check
them out get 20 off go to happyhippo.com
promo code is thick23. powders gummies
pills however you want get your grab
them do it with happy hippo Bronco thick
23.
let's get to the fight business here uh
there dude there is I know it's not a
fight week but there's a lot of news
there's a lot of news in the Real
Housewives of the UFC you had a fight
night uh this past weekend on Saturday
night
um obviously gamerat physieve didn't go
how we wanted it to physive uh broke his
foot right was it a foot no they think
they say me it looked like he hurt his
foot too is it just me did you see a
chin or no and it was it his knee from
what I saw yeah they haven't reported on
it yet there's no no legit actually new
source saying what happened to his
injury there just a broken foot you're
out a hot second torn ligaments out a
hot second you know yeah
see here
um UFC lightweight blah blah blah
keep going down
uh did you see you posted at the
hospital
well hopefully there's no ligament
damage done there not great or knee snap
is what it says here well that's not
good that's right you need just a snap
for the hell of it you know it's not
like you're anchor when it pops when
you're going upstairs if a knee snap
you're probably looking at some ligament
down she's out of hot set yeah uh you
know nothing against gamma he's a Savage
and then I think the talk of the night
was Bryce Mitchell over Dan ige Bryce's
getting pieced up
um but then you know Bryce was just
taking advantage in the grappling
department and that's why he won 3 27 29
20. I was more comfortable 29-28 because
the damage inflicted from Danny gay I
know how they scored damage I thought uh
29-28 but I think everybody had Bryce
Mitchell winning and that boy gets on
the mic and he goes full
full you know
Jesus yeah yeah a business great because
people think it's Bisping like oh we're
good but it's a producer in there like
no more no more we're good you know so
bizman was getting some heat for that
but he's just doing his job yeah you
can't let just some dude go wild on
there about the you know some of that
stuff but and he kept going and going
and going he's going hard on the page
yeah he's going hard in the page Danny
getting there too the only thing again
the only thing I like whether it's
Strickland whether it's Izzy
um any of these guys is if if that's him
do it run no matter whether I agree with
it or not do it if you think the Earth
is flat and you're the Heart of Heart
thing is flat run with it Daddy you know
that's why I'd prefer prefer a Bryce
Mitchell or a Sean Strickland opposed to
Kobe Covington now Kobe
stick obviously works but we know that's
not real he doesn't yeah that's not real
that's a very WWE type of gig he has
there but with Bryce Mitchell we know
that's just well that's in his place
that's in his veins and I appreciate it
I'm a huge fan
so uh but yeah as far as fight fights go
um the biggest one going down since
there's no UFC but uh just as big as one
Championship you got a big old one
Championship Rada Tang fought this uh
past weekend as well lost I thought he
won the fight I did too I think that
helps uh co-sign that it's DJ uh Mighty
Mouse also thought he won the fight yeah
but people are criticizing it because
it's like we're judging it from an MMA
point of view yeah we don't really know
Muay Thai yeah but we're right though
aren't we right I I decided one too the
other guy threw good kicks but I thought
Rob tank was going after it I did too
but again I don't have a trained eye for
Muay Thai so uh my I feel like Mighty
Mouse knows what he's doing though and a
lot of other experts you know are out
there saying rotting one so that's a
bummer yeah uh but probably my
top three uh favorite person to watch
fight in one Championship
um our girl stamp fear tax is fighting
this freaking weekend man
stamp uh you guys know her she's a two
sport one Champion world champion she uh
you know she won the first Adam weight
MMA Grand Prix for uh them and uh yeah
she beat uh oh no she was gonna
challenge Angela Lee
grocery fighting is on a nine fight
winning streak she's unbeaten in three
fights and one Championship I'm taking
stamp all freaking day she's so
entertaining and I get to see it
firsthand when I was in person and I
thought she was a big star like you know
kind of with the hard course here in
America dude when you see it in person
she's a superstar in Denver Colorado and
freaking Calabasas California over you
know over in Europe over in Asia she's
just a big ass star and I when she was
walking out and she does her dance she
looks all cute you're like you better
get your mind right girl and then she
gets in there and it's that's just her
thing she's so much fun to watch so damn
entertaining yep yep see her do her
thing number one verse number two is
going down for the interim Adam weight
uh World title and made this freaking
weekend and then also uh Daniel Kelly
who's one of my favorites the little
Phenom Jiu Jitsu is fighting Jessica
Khan Jessica Khan and uh that is the
first ever female Adam weight submission
grappling World title on one
Championship you you know what I'm
saying when my girl uh Daniel Kelly uh
Philly's Finest even though she lives in
Jersey though but she's Philly's Finest
born and raised in Philadelphia and we
had her to sit down they flew her out
from New York to sit down and she will
be on one-on-one with me this week to
preview her fight just her life
struggles everything she's gone through
to get to this point in her life and
she's one of the baddest women on the
freaking planet doing it she's doing it
in a major way because she's the this is
the first female world championship
title fight and this big of a program
ever so it's going down man it is going
down just Khan beat her before but that
was another promotion hot second ago so
um and Jessica Khan she's very
credentialed as far as legit GI Jiu
Jitsu very credentialed so uh Daniel
Kelly just she's a professional so you
see there's a different Dynamic there
Daniel Kelly's not worried about the ibj
FF all those that stuff
um ADCC she's not she doesn't care about
that all she cares about is being
professional win this title so uh you
know who I'm siding with so I'm excited
man I'm excited and I also have this
different uh set of rules fight going
down uh Wonder Girl is fighting it I
would how would you describe to I would
say it's basically MMA boxing yeah
because here's the rules you have young
young versus Wonder Girl
and
um here's the breakdowns it's three
rounds three minutes each
all punches are allowed no kicks no
knees no elbows
they're using a 10-point must system but
here's the thing so just punches are
loud nothing else four ounce MMA gloves
this base what Tyson Fury want to do
with Francis
boxing but in MMA gloves
could be dope
let's go down September 29th 8 PM
Eastern all right and that is on Amazon
Prime baby yeah
all right Tim what do you got
um all right there's a bunch of cool
fight announcements but oh the UFC is
just yeah but you get a fight you get a
fight you get a pretty good fight but
this came out just recently Israel
adesanya he pled guilty to driving drunk
in New Zealand it was like three weeks
before his fight
yeah when you look in the details of it
uh he was driving buzzed not defend him
you cannot drive drunk I think he just
barely made that limit yeah he barely
yeah it's like I think out there the
legal limits 50 milligrams per 100
milliliters of blood he was at 87 so
maybe had two drinks decided to drive
you know if you're tipsy you know Tipsy
driving is drunk driving we've all seen
those Billboards right
um but there's a difference between
being hammered and driving and Tipsy and
driving shouldn't do either yeah uh so
there's no defending Izzy here
the all this does is push the narrative
that Izzy didn't take Strickland serious
I would like to hear from Izzy Moore and
he on his YouTube channel he released
you know some stuff about the Strickland
fight but I'd like to hear more honest
opinion about this DUI because
again all this does is push the
narrative more that hurt Strickland's
performance ah dude Izzy was drunk
before the fight he was drinking that's
he didn't take Strickland serious man
that's how you know Izzy's gonna beat
him up next time they fight in the
rematch I don't
sign with that I I don't I don't tend to
head in that direction
um I'd be curious because I've known I
mean not myself I never drank maybe I
would have done better if I did but I
know a lot of guys at the highest the
high levels world champions who would
drink during Camp not get hammered but
have a few drinks with red wine GSP red
wine a beer hair some whiskey a little
tequila made a little cocaine you know
what I'm saying so some of you guys can
operate at a high level and still get
away with that stuff so if I I'd be
curious and again for idiot stuff
because he's
he's a role model so even my kid loves
Izzy he's seven he knows who is he is so
you don't want to say yeah I do drink
during Camp so he has to be kind of
delicate with this but I'm curious when
Izzy fought uh Alex Pierre this the
second time they drink they drink the
first time do you drink when he fought
Whitaker you know that would help you
know put push away the story of ah he
was even taking him serious
now if you're Izzy do you want this out
you know what I'm saying is this does
this do more good for Izzy going look
dude he was drinking during Camp that's
how you know he was in focused I'd like
Jeff is he's like every Camp including
uh you know all World title defenses
even when I lost I was drinking
like in hammered not drinking every
night not doing you know the wild boy
stuff but yeah I have a few drinks in
every Camp it helps me relax helps me
sleep I'm not saying that's the case
here I'm just curious if a he's done it
before
if B
he comes out and goes yeah dude I didn't
take Strickland serious I thought I was
gonna walk through him I was out till
three in the morning drinking didn't eat
right it was whatever dude we barely
trained for this
I'm curious I'd like to hear from him
not you know the forums and the chatter
the MMA Twitter none of that stuff I
want to hear it from the horse's mouth
has he done this before is this how he
usually operates
because that's going to help push aside
this narrative that Izzy wasn't prepared
or focused on Strickland at all because
again if he goes yeah when I knocked out
Whitaker when I act out Paulo Costa when
I fought you know insert big name you
know
has he done it before that's what I want
to know
it's a bomber I wonder if he was going
through some stuff too who knows
I I told you guys this heavy lies the
crown man when you're a champ it's a
different level of pressure especially
is he think of me title fights he's been
in all the marketing all the media all
the endorsements not the UFC
endorsements those or whatever I'm
talking about outside of that his
YouTube channel the merch there's all
this pressure on you you can pull it a
million different ways you gotta do this
media obligation so when you're the
champ heavy lies the crown I think he
was just like he's done it so much he's
been at the height of the sport the
thing he's just like I need a break and
this is his Outlet you know signs would
point to that
signs would point to that we've never
seen any of this behavior from Izzy
we've never seen him on folks in a fight
again is it a case my my only question
it can't come from anybody else not his
coach not his teammates has come from
Izzy
were you just over training you need a
break
or is this your typical behavior in Camp
and we're just now finding out about it
and you're that much of a badass you've
been able to kind of get by on drinking
and doing your thing and having fun you
know respond to trolls on social media
and you're still the baddest in the
middleweight division that's impressive
yeah does he does he have a splash of
Jon Jones in him you know
it makes him human dude it makes him
human everyone makes mistakes don't beat
him up too much
all right so moving on to the big fights
let's start with 295 the co headliner is
Europe this fight makes my wiener hard
if I could book one fight if the if Dana
White was okay man you can make one
fight this year this is the fight yeah
nothing makes me more excited for this
fight this is better than the main event
I'd rather watch this than the main
event dude Yuri versus Alex Pierre is
First Team all violence UFC 295 should
have those pictures of them with their
Warrior face paint on just say violence
that's what this fight is it's so damn
good I'm so excited for it
yeah for the title which is great
and then
UC 296 is freaking stacked so here's
what we have so far
you got Leon Edwards Kobe Covington they
announced that pantosia Brandon Roy Val
shout out to Brandon Roy Val for getting
it done
the the one that's getting the most
attention which we will focus on and get
to Tony Ferguson versus Patty pimlet
which I'm super excited for then shopcot
Wonder Boy Thompson UFC 296 is freaking
fantastic
and and then also on that is uh Vicente
Luken uh that was also announced like
yesterday you Machado Gary Vicente and
does that kick the main card off
I don't know it's still early so well
it's not even on the OC's website
yeah it is where what do you mean
it's on the website so yeah no talk
about Vicente Luke
oh gotcha but I assume because there's
only four fights on that main card yeah
so maybe Ian Gary's amazing for sure who
are you gonna put over I mean I guess
they could put him on the prelim main
that'd be silly engine is a big name
that is a fantastic card yes it is that
is the best card of the year
Wonder Boy Tony Patty pantosia Brandon
Roy Val Leon Edwards Kobe Compton and
Ian Gary
take my money I'm not stacked take my
freaking money uh so let's talk about
these matchups Leon Edwards Kobe
Covington is interesting interesting one
I had somebody in spoken at the meet and
greet asked me about who I have in that
fight
if Kobe was more active
I would take Colby all day Colby two
years off and Leon Edwards has been a
little more active and we've seen his
improvements against Kamala Usman I it's
it's a tough pick
if if if this is two years ago before
Kobe took all this time off and had the
issues with Jorge and you know you kind
of had this two-year laugh is a long
time dude long long time and then to
take those years off and then jump into
a title fight very tough and Leon
Edwards is only getting better his
takedown fence is only getting better so
we'll see we'll see the one thing Kobe
has on his side is that cardio
um you know so his last fight was March
5th 2022.
so he's looking at so March 5th 2022
he's fighting December of 2023 that's a
you know not two years but it's damn
near
it's a hot second it's a hot second
layoff to jump into a title fight
um and remember his last fight was
against you know or a friend of the show
Jory Mazda doll but he went from Camaro
to Jorge you know where he had a you
know was that Talent of his career so
um it's tough I'm a Kobe fan Big Kobe
fan like Leon Edwards too it's tough to
pick Kobe with that long layoff as good
as Leon Edwards looked against Kamara
Usman
so we'll see on that uh Pantoja Brandon
royville it's a fun fight
Brandon's earned it
um let's talk about the one everyone's
talking about Tony Ferguson Patty
pamlett
so when this first got announced
um a close friend of mine text me goes
it's not announced yet but I think
they're doing Ferguson versus Patty
pimlin and I go finally
finally Tony gets a winnable fight
person goes I agree he can win this one
I thought that was kind of the
General census
that everyone was like oh finally Tony's
gonna fight finally he gets not that's
an easy fight but he's look at look at
his last look at his last seven fights
strength of strength of schedule he's an
SEC dude this is his last
seven fights
Bobby green he got submitted right that
was a tough one uh but Nate Diaz
which was you know short short shorter
notice fight right Michael Chandler
Darius Charles Oliveira Justin gaichi
before that was Cerrone Anthony Pettis
Kevin Lee dos anjos what
looking through these kids fighting man
now I know he's lost one two three four
five six in a row I know he's lost six
in a row it doesn't look good but who'd
he lose to Justin gaichi how that
changed his life yeah that fight that
started it off gears off of him Justin
gaichi Charles Oliveira Darius I mean
what are we that's insane Michael
Chandler insane look pretty good on that
till you got Spartan kicked in the face
the Nate Diaz fight tough one Bobby
green tough one so the Nate Diaz by
Green very tough fights for him but just
look at that murderous Roe
impossible for him to win those fights
at where he's at right now
my my question for anybody out there
going I can't be UFC's doing this Tony
Ferguson we see what's going on here
it's clear as day they're just feeding
this young line to Tony Ferguson
my question for you guys is hey do you
really think Patty pillow won his last
fight
most don't so you're probably coming off
the loss of Jared Gordon okay uh before
that the only people of Patty's beat is
Jordan Levitt
uh uh Vargas
he he hasn't he's had they're impressive
fights he's been hitting all those
fights then the one fight where the guy
was pretty damn good he they gave him
the sin but most people think he lost
okay my question for you guys out there
who are so
so against this fight with Tony Ferguson
Patty pimlet
what aspect of mixed martial arts is
Patty pimlet better at than Tony
Ferguson
striking no
no
grappling
probably Patty's biggest asset you think
he's a better submission artist than
Tony Ferguson wrestling no way
you know better wrestling Tony
there's no way now
if this is
four years ago three years ago
Tony mops the floor with Patty at this
point but it's not it's a more weathered
slower uh less dangerous Tony Ferguson
but to say that Patty pimlets more
dangerous than Tony Ferguson is insane
to me
he's not a world-class Striker he's not
some guy where it goes down to the
ground it's over he's not a Damian Maya
down there
I I'm just and I'm not saying I'm
picking Tony to win all I'm saying is
this isn't a terrible fight for Tony
it's not some weird fight with UFC's
feeding this young lion this old
weathered veteran I look at that I go
literally my first instinct and the the
man who I was texting with knows the UFC
better than anybody I know goes yeah
thank God Tony finally got a favorable
fight I thought they I didn't think
about it man no [__] hell yeah
and then you go online people like oh
this is so disrespectful how can they
give tony a fine like whoa
I'm just reading the room wrong here
because I look at this go finally
they're giving Tony a break again not
saying he wins
but compared to his other fights
man I think he has a better chance than
this than he has in the past [__]
three years
I again my argument is and I you guys
know this I love Patty a huge fan of
Patty Patty has a ways to go before he's
a top 15 guy
Tony Ferguson's fought everybody as
dangerous as all get out even at his
ripe age of whatever he is in in fight
years 77. you know he's 39. get it older
you know world-class vet I get it all
the miles on him look bad in his last
fight doesn't look that version of Tony
that we're known and accustomed to when
he was probably the baddest 155 on the
planet uh him and khabib
and there was a time where if in the
prime I probably was side with Tony in
the prime never happened income fruition
but to say all this is ridiculous this
is so foul UFC this is so dark look how
they treat their vets I'm like ah ah
where is that energy when Frankie Edgar
had his last fight against that monster
I I don't see that I don't see that
angle here I look I go okay Patty's not
some dude who's gonna throw some crazy
flying knee or you know some crazy
knockout artist okay I like that this
could be a war this is perfect for Tony
again not saying he wins but damn
compared to Justin Gates you Charles
Oliveira Darius Michael Chandler Nate
Diaz Bobby green
okay
perfect
and this and I think there should be
Tony's last fight win or lose if he wins
this get out of there dude trust me
you're not gonna get another one of
these get out of there
it gets worse from here if you win this
one they're not going to give you
another matchup like this I like it if
you're a Tony fan you're like okay I can
see him win this one you're not saying
that when he's fighting gate you you're
not saying that when he's fighting
Charles all over you're not saying that
when he fights Darius I'm not saying
that we fought Michael Chandler we
fought Nate Diaz the Bobby green like oh
my God Bobby's so explosive this is a
bad idea
I see Patty I'm like hmm I could see him
winning this one
or I could see him losing but he's not
going to get absolutely starched I'll
take it
yeah were you guys against it no we all
said it's a great matchup were you cool
with it too or no
yeah I think it's his best matchup that
he's gotten in the past seven by two
percent but do you think Patty wants it
yeah yeah yeah I mean the odds are Patty
wins I'm just saying it's not like he's
this plus one one thousand hundred
dollar plus 240. okay yeah that's about
right you guys don't want to fight in a
hot second all I'm saying this isn't
some master it's not like Hamza Nate
Diaz that was ridiculous that was
clearance day what the UFC was doing
we're like what and even the UFC was
like holy [__] we gotta change this up
and they switched them because it was so
wrong to do that this isn't that this is
like good send off for Tony win or lose
he's not he's not going to get
completely annihilated they're not
giving them just engage on his final
send-off
not giving them fuzzy some dude who's
just some Savage who you're gonna see
Tony get hurt by with Pat I'm like all
right thinking of grappling exchange I
want to see what happens here it's a
good fight for Patty who we love here
love absolutely love Patty
good fight for Pat you beat a guy like
Tony Ferguson even though he's lost six
good feather in the cap for Tony you got
this young buck who's not this crazy
knockout artist who isn't some explosive
dude who where you're gonna end up on
ESPN highlight in Flatline I like it
that's all I'm saying I like it
shaft got one boy Thompson I think out
of all the fights that's a very tough
fight for sure I've got
tough fighting people think I would
assume shop got uh is there odds on that
I'll check
that's not walking the park for shopkat
uh minus 465. so he's a he's a bigger
favorite than Patty over Tony yeah
and you guys are cool with this one
though
not you guys online you guys are cool
with this one because Wonder Boys older
than Tony I know he looks better inside
the doctor I'm just saying Wonder Boys
older than him they're getting shot cut
he's a minus 465 favorite
if you have to bet on Underdog would you
bet on Wonder Boy Tony
Wonder Boy you guys are pieces of [__]
yeah me too me too yeah me too me too me
too
oh that card's tasty though yeah
yeah tasty
and Lucy versus Gary that's gonna be
that should be tough for Gary right
uh Vicente Luke in Gary Gary's gonna
have such a reach Advantage you guys
know how I feel about Ian Machado Gary
Vicente Luke is such a Savage right so
good at everything
it's just a awful matchup for Vicente
Luce
very tough fight for him
very very tough fight for him
very tough fight
I got you and Gary all day on that yeah
we going Sizzler
five days a week because then it's Off
to the Races then we're because Vicente
Lucas ranked what right now
10.
uh and they got Ian at 11. yeah you beat
him then then it's off the races
uh so what's gonna happen is Ian Gary
versus Vicente Luke a winner I assume
will fight Wonder Boy or shopkat
especially shaft guy I think he has a
little more work to do he needs some
bigger names in his cap
it's weird they still have Hamza at um
four
he moved on
you know
what else you got you
let's see
oh so this was uh Francis and Ghana was
on Joe Rogan's podcast and then you know
I think Wilder also accused Tyson fear
of cheating with the glove somehow so
you can punch through the side you know
all these he just had like video
evidence apparently and it looked like
the glove was floppy
so now Francis is saying that him and
his team will have to double check even
if the commission says it's good they
have to see it themselves they do that
anyways though you have one someone from
your corner looking at them laced up the
gloves that's nothing new it's a
narrative it's something to say I guess
for Francis to poke at Tyson but you
don't get tysonself by cheating with
your gloves that's so stupid I thought
the takeaway from that was I think it's
good for Rogan I'm sure Rogan knows but
it's good when you hear it from the
horse's mouth with Francis the way the
UFC manipulates the contracts yeah the
extension stuff the extension so he was
like you know I was hurt I want to fight
in july that I'm gonna fight in June I
was like uh what no I'm good
like oh we're just checking we're just
checking then you notice extension in
the mail so it's their way and he was
like I only have a year left it's their
way of keeping you it's like six months
it's so dirty it's uh yeah oh it's six
months yeah it's crazy it was the same
thing with the ultimate fighter contract
you remember I was like wait I'm done I
thought like no dude you got two more
fights like no no I thought it was a
four-year deal they're like yeah but
that one time where after your fight and
you didn't go like what and back in the
day they didn't even send you the notice
you would go into the negotiation think
you were done they're like oh no you
actually got a year left because
remember we hinted the idea of you
fighting Brock Lesnar hinted at the idea
of you fighting stuff on struve and then
you said you want to fight later I'm
like yeah we had a discussion like yeah
it's basically turned down a fight like
what
so it's just it's good to see the the
underbelly of the business it's a it's a
dark business they're gonna you know
it's the fight business you know
every fighter is like yeah that's how it
goes but I think it's good for the
public to hear that's that's what your
animal you're dealing with one of the
tactics yeah yeah it's not cool yeah and
the sponsors where you lost a 1.2
million dollar in crypto because they
signed with crypto and then
and you signed with UFC right after yeah
and then new company's like sorry dude
now we can't work it he's like oh this
is ridiculous UFC's like we'll take all
the money
but here's 10 grand put that on your
shorts and you have no say
stuff yeah
you get it from both sides you get from
the UFC business standpoint and then for
the fighters it's a nightmare
yeah but it seems like they are really
really wanting all their money in every
possible way possible the UFC that's why
that's like just as much as possible I
know that's why they have so much money
that's why I couldn't run the UFC
yeah you can't you gotta be cut throat I
couldn't do it
all right so this is just a Time Woodley
was on a rampage Jackson's podcast
recently and he for I didn't know he had
any issues with Izzy but I guess he says
he wants to beat the [__] out of him why
if they're uh if he ever made a comeback
he'd want to fight Izzy something weird
where he said like
um oh he says because he's capped that's
fake that's what the kids say what
what's weird I can understand cap if it
was a way shorter version of the word
fake it's not like fake's a long word
right yeah
okay so because I'm not gonna say cap
because I'm 40. uh because he's fake
what they said he was never Izzy
arasanya how do I do this again Izzy
adesanya I get on the same show TMZ and
they asked me who was uh who was next up
I said I kind of like this Israel kid
he's kind of different but he's got some
Pizzazz he's got uh his own character
he's flashy but he's good martial artist
he's one of the one to watch out for
this when he first started out so I gave
him respect then they asked me who did I
want to fight whoever's at the top so
you're at the top my brother it's a
salute I never wanted to fight Nick Nate
Diaz or Conor McGregor or George Saint
Pierre because I thought they were weak
easy and whack yeesh
uh I thought they was the best to be the
best you got to beat the best okay kind
of confusing but he basically said you
know he was giving Israel a compliment
by saying he'd want to fight him because
he's a good fighter and I guess Izzy you
know didn't take it well and now he
wants to beat the [__] out of him but it
is he say anything back I didn't see
anything with is he saying so clearly
Woodley's Master wouldn't take into
Conley by uh Izzy who fired back in a
series of interviews Willie went on to
lose the title
okay
interesting
I mean Woodley and his yard never
fighting all right this is outside the
UFC I don't see the UFC bringing Woodley
back I love Whitley Woodley but I think
those days are over
yeah there's so many issues with the UFC
I just don't see him come in agreement
yeah and there's so much movement at
middleweight I just don't see it
happening
um also uh Rampage said that when he
went to the Jake
yeah Jake Paul Nate Diaz fight that uh
when he saw Nate in the locker room hit
one of his pecs was smaller than the
other so he's like what the hell
happened he tore us back no so
apparently Nate said that he had a
pinched nerve in his back and then so
you know you know your muscles kind of
well that that means it was pinched for
a hot SEC yeah I had it when I was in
college playing football I got so many
stingers the nerve endings in my arm
like just
losing muscle yeah so my right arm was
small on my left arm yeah it sucks so we
must have had that for a hot second yeah
so just Randy saying like you know
that's pretty dope that he went out
there to fight still yeah he was really
injured that's why he had to fight a
certain way too he this I think he said
something he had to fight Mexican style
because that's cool yeah yeah NATO
Savage
uh this is a little older but I don't
think we discussed it Mike Perry says
that his new deal with bkfc because he
signed with them and not anyone else uh
is around eight million dollars damn
yeah guarantee he said all together if
that's if he wins all of his fights I
have to say they put about 8 million on
contract let's go ahead and put that out
there because F them they've got to
fight me now because I'm ready to make
this money I got this money on paperwork
I got this house I'm paying for I've got
this family I'm paying for I've got all
these expensive things going on I'm
ready to fight promote talk some smack
and punch some people in the face
eight meal for Mike Perry that's pretty
awesome I need a breakfast meal though
yeah I'm guessing it's an eight mil if
you go undefeated you know or is it a
guaranteed eight Mill
yeah mbft bkfcs had their struggles
paying people trust me
all right
um
now we won't do that one this is just a
quick one because Misha hasn't been
fighting for a while I guess and she's
coming back to fight Julia Avila I'll
take it December Fight Night never met
with me she'll fight that's Misha's
record right now so lost your last two
and the girl she's fighting is
should have lost one of her last two
coming off a win though yeah
uh this was super dope
so I guess Korean zombie he said during
when he was leaving the Octagon or
whatever someone took his gloves you
know his retirement gloves yeah so max
Holly found out that story and Max
always said I'm gonna send you you know
my gloves from the fight because that's
the memory from the fight as well so he
sent those in
so he can have him sent those two Korean
zombie okay that's like the Korean
Zombie Road Max Holly just sent me his
gloves as a gift and then after that
Korean zombie and his team donated 20
000 to the Maui Food Bank oh it's dope
yeah that's great
yeah
now according to Bryce Mitchell Satan
started those fires
he says a lot of stuff it wasn't it
wasn't uh natural fire is what he said
but yeah
yeah he's going through some stuff
though man his personal life with his ex
and all that stuff there's a lot going
on yeah
um
I don't think we talked about this but
so Angela Lee revealed recently that
when she did have she had a crash I
remember that too when I had to uh she
said it was an accident it was actually
a suicide attempt oh that's horrible and
then she does now finally admit that her
little sister did con you know she took
her own life which is horrific horrible
yeah
horrible but uh damn so that so her
sister I wonder if the brother or and I
don't you know mental health does it
is it genetic can it carry down I think
so
but I mean I have people in my family
that struggle with it I don't so I don't
know if it's hereditary you know but
that's terrible that poor fam I love
Angela Lee
yeah I guess none of them really talked
about it so now they're finally talking
about so hopefully the kid you know the
the one little brother and the other
brother hopefully now that they're
talking about it they can open up if
they're dealing with these issues see
how horrible my speaker Angela is a dime
yeah and she's a champion yeah you know
her family comes from you know they're
all fighters yeah monsters yeah
it's horrible that was like one of the
saddest things area her little sister
like awful unimaginable
oh there's gonna be some sort of
announcement too from Angel Lee on the
fight night or fight
again right I don't know if she's gonna
make an announcement yeah godspeed man
it's terrible yeah
um Chris leiban I guess the last fight
that just happened that's his first
debut in Nevada as a judge
so he's judging and refereeing that's
what you need especially if they're a
sound mind that's what you need you need
former fighters who know what the hell's
going on so they're not giving 10-8
rounds
for no reason yeah
all right um can we take a little break
and do a Arcadia read oh I can't wait
for Arcadia Arcadia is a festival that
is happening November 2nd through the
5th at area 15. not to be confused with
Area 51 don't show up to Area 51 you're
probably gonna get arrested come to Area
15 in Nevada all right and it's hosted
by my boy Aubrey Marcus featuring
Headliners Chromeo I love their music Dr
fresh elderbrook Jai Wolf The Glitch Mob
Troy boy it's all going down that is
November 2nd through the 5th area 15.
it's gonna be a great grand old time
this is your chance to be part of
something legendary stuff in the world
where anything is possible and the
beauty of human expression takes Center
Stage as we come together to create a
More Beautiful World tickets are selling
out so get your freaking tickets all you
got to do is head to fitforservice.com
Arcadia with a K we're at
a-r-k-a-d-i-a right now again that's fit
for service.com slash a r k a d i a you
got Chromeo performing my boy Aubrey
Marcus hosting get you some Area 15 not
to be confused with area 51.
all right
see here oh
have you seen as in Barbosa lately this
is him now
Jackson super Jack and he posted this
video he got obviously I think after he
posted that picture he posted I was like
we'll do that over
and then he shows like a side by side
here
look at that difference nuts dude yeah I
don't know what he's thinking but he's
like
straight it too like I just jacked it
like it looks like he got leaner input
that that's when my skeptical hip lies
go off when someone gets leaner that
could be diet leaner with more muscle is
very difficult to do but more power
doing
whatever he's doing is working and
whatever acai some of them Brazilians
are taking he got his hands on it yeah
yeah enjoy that wheel kick and I just
saw this from Todd Duffy he looks
freaking jacked and lean he's always
been jacked but now he's even leaning he
looks like
um the dude from Beauty and the Beast he
does he looks like a prince yeah
and he was supposed to fight a ryzen I
think a few days ago or this weekend but
something to do with the I don't know
Visa or something happen
but there you go yeah he's jacked I love
Todd Duffy he's a great dude Savage too
super Savage is that itching that's
pretty much it dude because we got
three parts three parts yes we do yeah
Steve rinella coming in on firing the
kid Steve's one of my favorites and then
we have a medium also a ghost guy
Jonathan Mark Jonathan Mark which is my
that's my thing that's my thing y'all
clearly I booked that guest can you tell
who Brian booked and who I booked I got
the ghost Guy Brian got Steve all right
he's gonna do a reading on you and
broccoli I think yeah yeah that's gonna
be dope we just got Brian can't be so
like anti-ghost yeah like you got to
give into it you know what I'm saying
otherwise we don't have a show that's
like me being anti-hunting or a vegan
and bringing Steve Brunell on you don't
have a show it could be fun if you argue
about it uh this week this weekend I
will be at skank Fest that's right your
boys come to skank Fest it's me and
Brian count together at skank Fest we're
doing a live pod with this gang Fest
Bros that's big Jay Gomez
um who am I forgetting big J Luis Gomez
um all the boys from uh skank s will be
on stage uh Dave Smith he'll be there as
well
um it's so it's gonna be fine on the kid
skank Fest live pod I think that's at
8pm Friday night I have a set earlier
that day on Friday they have two sets
Saturday night that's skank Fest Las
Vegas Thursday I will be at Overkill in
Sacramento turning my TRX to a demon TRX
SRT Hellcat baby I can't wait uh outside
that I'm in Iowa October 13th and 14th
Niagara Falls November 4th and 5th those
are almost sold out so get your tickets
Niagara Falls New York tickets just went
on sale uh on my end but they've done
the work on their end so that bad boys
so to my fans get tickets now Niagara
Falls New York Chicago in December uh
get your tickets got a bunch of more
tour dates being announced new tour
being announced new management holler at
your boy all right
um but skank Fest see you this freaking
week in Las Vegas Nevada then Iowa
Niagara Falls New York Chicago for the
rest of year but uh that's it I will be
documenting creating dope content
turning my TRX and over a thousand
horsepower demon Hellcat alright so
thank you guys for tuning in enjoy one
championship this freaking weekend the
best to do it stamp Fair Texas find
Daniel Kelly that's all going down on
Amazon Prime one Championship get you
some till next time be safe
see you guys love you